uh Liam welcome to St Louis chess club
and Grand chess tour it's really nice to
see you here I know that it's not your
first time that you participate in in
those events do you have some great
memories from the previous ones can you
share with us definitely so the first
year I came to America was 2013 and
actually that year I was the uh Reserve
player for the snu cup the first SFU cup
ever and um I always wanted to play in
this event and um first time I really
play in
the in the St Louis rapid and place was
2017 and then in
2021 uh I play another one here so uh
now in 23 I got another chance to play
here so always very excited to come back
here um and play chess it's is the best
place to play chess in America and
probably in the world as well so very uh
excited for that yeah in 2017 you had a
chance to play against even gar KAS far
if you were lucky that you played in the
tournament I think you have even you
beat him yes in this that event yeah I
um I lost in the rapid game I play The
Rook very very badly um but in the BL I
think I got one win in one dra yeah
that's great and I know that you live in
St Louis and now actually you're head of
the program in Webster University how is
it to how you are combining your career
as a coach and the professional chess
player yeah so
um coincidentally U Webster University
started a chess program uh in 20 uh 2012
so few years before the St Louis
University but um we have been um very
successful in the last 11 years uh Susan
ponga um she was the head coach for 9
years and then after she retired I took
over the position I this is my third
year uh coaching the team so I have been
really enjoying doing that um it's
always a pleasure to work with such a
strong team with very talented and
dedicated players and I like to help
them um I want to share my experience
with them and help them become the best
players they can be um as for myself I
still see myself as a very competitive
player and I like to participate in
strong events uh nowadays I don't get a
lot of time to travel and and play a lot
of tournaments like I used to but um I
always enjoy all the tournaments I want
to play and um for example this one um I
got invite um just a few weeks ago um
but um it's a very pleasant surprise and
of course I didn't hesitate to to accept
because it's some always a very
interesting and challenging uh event to
play yeah uh um did you have any special
preparation for these few weeks that you
had um so I didn't do really any
specific prep for this uh but more like
General preparation about openings about
skills in general
um as I said I didn't know about this
about my participation in this
tournament until few weeks ago so I
didn't really prepare too much but I
think listen rapid it will mostly come
down to your farm your um nerve and uh
it's not too much about preparation mhm
I I've been following your career
actually since the uh the moment you won
a FL open and then you became the world
Blitz champion in hunting if I'm not
mistaken and um I mean do you think you
had enough opportunities in your chess
professional life to play on the top
events I mean how was your life as a
professional chess player during those
years after actually you reached quite a
good success in in the Chess World yeah
those are my good years yeah I remember
you were there in uh 2013 yes 201 yes
so yeah I could
say I as a player who grew up in in
Vietnam um I didn't have access to that
many tournaments um like I wanted to um
also at that time 10 20 years ago we
didn't have as many tournaments as we do
today so it was a bit small challenging
at that time which is why I moved to
America in 2013 uh for more tournaments
and and also a chance to work with uh
strong players um when I came here my
teammates at Webster University were uh
R Robson wesle so uh we have like 10 GMS
so um it really helped my chest to move
here and been around um surrounded by
many players that also motivate you to
work harder um I got to play quite a few
tournaments that I like and I did quite
well as well um so I have no regrets
about my career um now that I'm not so
young anymore I don't have that much
Ambitions uh as as I had when I was a
younger player but I still enjoy it a
lot and all the tournaments I play I try
to do my best what about this event what
is your like goal in this tournament uh
I don't think I can set a clear goal
like winning the tournament of finishing
second or third I mean I don't think
anyone what would be the good result
what will be the good result for you
I'll just take it game by game my main
goal is just not to blunder uh not to
lose badly um as long as I feel like I'm
learning from the game I'm learning from
my mistakes and hopefully there are not
too many uh mistakes uh then I would be
happy um in general I mean I'm one of
the lowest rated players in this
tournament so uh if I could finish maybe
on the uh upper half that would be that
would be great yeah all the best of luck
for Liam thank you very
[Music]
much